be strong with it once you can do catch
it Sacramento has one timeout left
they're gonna go for to 112 109 41
seconds left
both teams over the limit things are on
11-3 run Ruiz almost stole that ball
that's why I say grant pick up in half
pressure because those are the type of
things that happen you miss an
opportunity now Alvin Gentry will take a
timeout so Alvin Gentry with a timeout
this has kind of been the story grant on
the right hand side of your screen is on
holiday and look who else is coming to
the game at the copier strand JJ Redick
yes Redick has not played at all until
now in this fourth quarter here we go
we'll see if the Kings can get the stop
that they need
[Applause]
holidays traffic holiday
four to shoot Linux not the guy you want
to have the ball but the Kings get it
and the rebound favors and hold
everything we've got a foul underneath
on Holmes loose ball foul that's going
to be free-throws and if they make one
the game's probably in Hey
but there are favors again not a real
good free-throw shooter at 50% that
right there would be the tenth offensive
rebound
[Applause]
just got to get in here and get it favor
says may both of his free-throws in this
game
if he misses this do you take a timeout
or do you go well well I would think
that they already have a play drawn up
and I think look the same though you got
to communicate if your buddy here here
in five
[Applause]
box out the cheetah
got a score to hurry
homes 6.5 seconds and you pal holiday
and obviously if it makes both this
ballgame through holiday a 70%
free-throw shooter he has not been to
the line can you would think a guy like
true holiday would it be better at the
line than 70% yeah but 70% doesn't
necessarily say what he does in the
clutch time and no you're right he's a
clutch type of player that is for sure
but the Kings
[Applause]
the elites are coming in for a rebound
which tells you that they're going to
take a timeout if he misses this even if
he makes it
[Applause]
Wow goodness gracious but change the tie
the game what on earth are the pelicans
thinking about oh wait ask for a miracle
and we may have just gotten one Doug
Preston we've got to hit the free coke
oh wow night never new comes off Peter
behind the line no doubt about it off
the glass
yes it's Saturday Bank is open 4.2
seconds left and Emin yuppie ELISA can
tie the game now Alvin Gentry could
challenge this he's got a timeout left
but he may need the timeout to set up
the final play with 4.2 Brandon Ingram
also has fouled out keep that in mind at
this
goes to overtime but if you are the
Kings guards you want to crash right now
just in case anemone misses teams
haven't been good at the free-throw line
tonight so make sure that you get in
[Applause]
pelicans have a timeout left
lemon yuppie elites up at the line these
two of dreams
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
electra back in 115 to 115 with 4.2 the
keys needed a miracle
then they got one did you ask for a
grand that's exactly what they got but I
will tell you what you're going to need
right now is a defense to stop on this
end of the floor no doubt about it the
Bank is open them in you get some feet
said 610 I reach up I knock down a lot
of time left up with 4.2 you don't you
don't have a foul to give going down to
the wire
Kings are on a 12 3 runs greater than
Ingram has fouled out
[Applause]
is JJ reddick he'll let the silence the
crowd 1.1
time outs left no timeouts left the
Reese's got to get up he's hurt
[Applause]
and the war lenders gets the bed playing
basket pyretic